[Music]
dishes guys dating don't you say this
like every time hey it's chris and i
feel like you can tell a lot about a guy
just based on his cooking so mary you're
going to try three different dishes
cooked by three different guys and then
you get to decide who you are going on a
date with just based on this cooking
sound good sounds good hi my name is
mary i was born in phnom penh cambodia i
was adopted when i was a baby so i've
lived in the u.s for most of my life so
i'm looking for kind of an all-around
great god as long as like on his free
time or when he comes home from work he
wants to do something like a little bit
adventurous but also a guy that kind of
will add a little bit of like spice and
oomp to my life hi i'm nick hi i'm rithi
hey i'm robert are you getting nervous
i'm feeling okay i'm pretty confident in
what i've made follow your taste buds
mary
this is a dish called numpa chalk
something my mom used to make a lot when
i was growing up my mom would often call
it cambodian spaghetti put more effort
than i needed to and like just making
each stock myself fish stock chicken
stock fermented fish paste my holy
trinity with the the
it's a common paste found in everything
so it's like kefir lime galanga garlic
lemongrass add some spice really bright
and vibrant but also with like all these
sides it can be like a little diy choose
your own adventure type thing this is
actually my first time making it i
definitely wanted to be as authentic to
cambodian queens as possible because i
feel like it's very underrepresented so
go big or go home so this was definitely
not
an easy dish to make so if she tastes it
she should immediately say family guy
appreciates his roots
high effort hopefully we'll see
fire away
it's like noodles i don't know the name
of the dish i don't remember the name of
the dish either thanks chris
i like how it's customizable i'm just
gonna like add this stuff in
yeah i'm so sorry if i'm doing this
wrong she doesn't know what it is yeah
she doesn't seem very cambodian you
shouldn't be talking
even i know what this is
i'm pleasantly surprised it's really
good very flavorful at least she likes
it overall would you go on a date with
this guy and why i would definitely give
him a shot
i would say this is a very thoughtful
and well put together dish
i mean she likes it i like how like
organized it is and then he gave me the
options of what i want to put in there
so that's thoughtful but also maybe he's
like a little bit too particular about
things that's just how it's served
normally i don't want to say that
actually
normally though i don't know if that's a
good or bad thing like sometimes it's
good sometimes it's bad but overall
great job you like it how he appreciates
and respects your independence and
autonomy that compliments it very well
drawing so much information out of this
dish right here well i appreciate it
anything else you want to say about this
guy great guy
okay cool
[Music]
so this is going to be a meat-heavy type
platter i know based on her instagram
that she's really into fitness so
protein is key i've never made any of
these dishes before so i had to do a lot
of research on how to make chrome paste
which is the the marinade which is heavy
on lemongrass galangal macro lime leaves
and a lot of other aromatic flavors
because it's meat heavy i also included
a papaya salad to bring out that acidity
and sourness to kind of cut that meat we
got guy number two
okay
looks very pretty
this guy gave me options as well so
cheers to that it's not even that's just
how it's served
okay
not bad very lukewarm response right
here i want to say that's lamb lamb no
beef somewhere there he tried out like
six different types of beef i like this
one better the rice has a lot of flavor
question is did you cook that
traditional asian way you put a rice
cooker rice cooker
minus coin no no no stop you can use a
rice cooker if i'm gonna be like
nitpicky about it the meats are a little
dry
didn't you marinate overnight i did it's
the microwave is his personality drive
i'm just kidding
like yo my competition i felt that would
you date him is that a red flag i would
consider going on a date with him i
think it's like a well put together dish
the meat is flavorful
but a little dry so maybe you're like
flavorful but dried
you're known for now no flavorful but
i'm a dry guy now maybe he like likes to
do adventurous things but like maybe
works like a boring nine to five or
something that's kind of the vibe i'm
getting from this dish you've got your
day job but then you go home and you
just like go to the club or something do
something crazy at night oh
complete opposite
i would just say that i think he's
probably overall a nice guy who just
needs a little spice in his life
well i really like veggie so i usually
focus on dishes with the majority
vegetable especially i also prefer white
meat over red meat so lots of fish lots
of chicken i think it almost showed that
i'm like really healthy which is a diet
that i grew up with really like the
vibrant really fresh veggie freshly cut
this is a really nice garnish for the
sauce the more like a dip this is a bit
out of fish tilapia and i'm plating it
by kind of having the the meat and then
having the sauce around it which is a
very common plating in cambodia nice and
clean and easy to look at my mom's a
great cook and i've always been her sous
chef since i was little i think the dish
is going to really highlight that of
like who i am and the type of diet i eat
every day guy number three oh
very colorful ah see that's what i was
going for and i'm not sure what that is
i think like maybe i'm supposed to like
dip the veggies in that yeah it's like a
dip
um
like bland
oh
it's like i can tell you tried to put
thought into it but it's kind of just
like vegetables on a plate so you're
like hot on the outside but like really
like boring and blind on the inside
the wrong direction he did steam some of
it he steamed the asparagus and oh okay
but he didn't cut the ends off of the
asparagus oh she caught that he didn't
cook and it's cooking competition i made
the dip
that's cooking i mean he had to pick out
all the vegetables and wash them and cut
them individually right i'm just trying
to give him a fighting chance over here
no i get what you're saying but i still
see like kind of like minimal effort put
into this i mean that was supposed to
like represent my personality right i
just do like really simple minimalistic
you can be minimalistic and flavorful i
think there just needs to be like a
little more oomph here i think it's very
like pretty surface level
but like nothing else is there
we have three very different guys here
which one do you want to go on a date
with
so
the third guy i
liked how colorful the dish was i will
take that as a compliment you've been
too optimistic right now
but it did lack the
effort the spice and the flavor so
unfortunately it won't
be the third
the
second guy i'm like a sucker for like
rice and meat so i love that part of it
and there was like a lot of flavor there
but the meat tended to be like a little
bit dry but i love the effort but
unfortunately it just didn't have the
extra oomph that i was looking for but
the first guy had kind of a little bit
of everything he had the flavor he had
the options kind of the customizable
part so i think maybe he's like a
well-rounded like all-around like great
personality great guy i hear no lies
has a lot of like fun spice and flavor
in him so the winner is the first guy
thank you mary cool you ready to meet
him yeah okay
all right come on in mary see the girl
who broke a heart
not mine
hi hello hello hi i'm nick i'm ruthie
i'm robert mary you selected nick as
your date all right you guys have
anything to say to her how do you let
you guys go i mean all i got from that
was she thought i was attractive i will
take that
robert are you as dry as she assumed
i'm the mr dry personality at your
accused but no i i am not like that i
think like uh the microwave really must
taste get them dirty
all right so i'm gonna send you guys off
on a little mini date you can talk on
your own for a bit and then we'll check
back in later and see what you want to
do after that sound good sounds good
cool
all right so now you can go ahead
whenever you're ready just get down on
one knee can one of you guys go get the
ring oh yeah
how accurate were you i think i was
pretty accurate i think all around he's
a great guy very flavorful right
just for a second i forgot what dish he
was
you already forgot my dish was she
accurate in her assessment of myself
yeah i mean i was very proud of my dish
like i knew if like my mom took about it
right now she'd be like that's how i
raised you
noodle guy where are you taking her on a
date oh i know
there is a fantastic place it's in times
square called red lobster times square i
don't know if you've ever been there
before
backup option if they're too backed up
uh the olive garden let's do it any last
words great job good job guys decide to
go to red lobster
[Music]